next 2023 starts tomorrow
the anticipation of innovation fills the
air Debbie is a data engineer and she's
getting ready to make her way to the
convention
she double checks the next website to
confirm the time of the opening keynote
at 9am on Tuesday August 29th and Views
the rest of the daily agenda along with
some available sessions Debbie's
colleague can't make it to next in
person so Debbie suggests he register
for the complimentary digital pass which
allows him to watch all the great
sessions from next 23 on demand at his
convenience Debbie is excited and ready
to learn from and network with all the
attendees at next
are you ready for next
foreign